a china uma casa feminista calma nosso
sustento era uma casa assim tão
diferente das outras que dizer que ele
era um bocadinho que isto que chega numa
casa feminista e oxi e ver o meu pai e
minha mãe a fazer é mais ou menos as
mesmas tarefas
eu não mexi só pedir amor à minha mãe ou
a ter só respeito pelo meu pai eu
cheguei a ter amor e respeito pelo pai e
amor e respeito pela minha mãe e que o
mpm ensinaram desde pequenina que eu
podia ser que o que eu quisesse
independentemente do gênero do sexo com
quem ache que homens e mulheres podiam
fazer exatamente as mesmas coisas mas
leva crer em trabalhar em preço e que
esteja mais ou menos o conceito do que
era o feminismo
agora o colchão que lhe fui para a
escola primária e conseguia dizer às
pessoas que era feminista e os outros
miúdos do emirato eu confesso na altura
também não sabia muito bem ainda definir
o conceito olharam para mim com ora se
um caso estranho e começaram a dizer
a google não gosto de meninos que gosta
de meninas
enganaram-se depois o que se mais um
carinho e voltei a insistir na questão
do feminismo explicar aos meus colegas
não querem mais vezes como era a vida lá
em casa que um dia era a minha mãe que
eu fazia um jantar e nesse dia o pai
lavar louça no dia a seguir ao contrário
que os dois eram os meus em ter gatos de
educação para não ter que ser sempre o
mesmo a faltar ao trabalho para poder ir
às urnas na escola que os dois outros
navios vidas comigo a pediatra e que os
dois tomavam todas as decisões da minha
vida e tenho todas as responsabilidades
só pra mim eu não estava apenas em que
retirava a ser educada mais pela minha
mãe
então a gente acho isso muito estranho
chegaram inclusive a dizer que minha mãe
era uma preguiçosa que não queria
trabalhar com mulheres que não levavam
sempre as escadas e que não levavam sem
problemas e não faziam sempre jantar
eram isso mesmo preguiçosas e durante
muito tempo habitual manter fora de casa
impulso diferente daquilo que eu tenho
em casa
lembro que era o feminismo e confesso
que tem muitas vezes porque não é por
causa disso porque quem achar que era
uma coisa tão mal vista como aconteçam
tão negativa
não vale a pena estar a discutir quando
no fundo e e aqui vou já desvendaram que
ninguém sobre aquilo que vou falar mais
à frente
o filme já é hoje é que o que sempre foi
a luta pela igualdade de gênero pela
igualdade de direitos e oportunidades
entre os dois sexos
depois quando fui para a faculdade e
continue a dizer que mesmo assim era
feminista chegaram a dizer que ser
feminista é igual é queimar sutiãs o que
significava que o conheceram igual aos
homens o que significava que eu queria
ser um homem
isso é uma coisa que sempre foi
incomodando muito há dois ou três anos
eu comecei a ver as coisas mudarem
eu comecei a sentir essencialmente essa
mudança três das redes sociais
não sei ver box de mulheres famosas a
dizerem que iriam ganhar exatamente o
mesmo que os homens que eram capazes de
fazer exatamente as mesmas coisas
não sei ver campanhas virais como uma
pessoa há uns anos nos estados unidos em
que o estudante universitário chamado
bloco externa teve uma pena muito leve
três meses por ter violado uma colega
o juiz ou dava uma coisa do gênero do
que o tenha sido ligeiramente provocado
pelas circunstâncias e gerou-se uma
campanha viral completamente viral nas
redes sociais a denunciar a situação e
foi aí que eu comecei a perceber
fui ler a placa de um flerte entre
nacionais começando a virar mas pode
livre e fui me apercebi italiana chega
uma nova vaga de feminismo luta pela
exatamente pelas mesmas coisas mas que
já não está tão fechado na caminha já
não está tão fechado sempre os mesmos
grupos de discussão como é uma
intelectual por exemplo e que junta
diferentes tipos de mulheres
nós hoje temos aquelas modelos super
giras da victoria's secret que desfilam
a enfatizar em agir depois a
manifestarem-se nas ruas por salários
iguais contra o assédio sexual verbal
por direitos e oportunidades iguais para
todas as mulheres e final estável no
futuro mesmo como vocês podem ver não
tenha ensinado que estão em frente às
nossas lutas hoje em dia é que são
diferentes são diferentes porque amo
eu costumo chamar que são os números da
realidade em portugal a diferença
salarial entre homens e mulheres é de
16,7 por cento aprender causar mais
claro o que quer dizer que o homem
mulher fazendo exatamente o mesmo
trabalho eu ganha mais do que ela
mais de 80 por cento das mulheres
portuguesas têm aquilo que chama a dupla
jornada de trabalho que é nada mais nada
menos do que acumular todas as
responsabilidades da casa e dos filhos
com o trabalho o que lhes faz com que
elas estejam mais cansadas faz com que
os tratamentos disponíveis para o
trabalho por conter sempre ser mais
chato porque tem que buscar as crianças
na escola porque tem que ir às reuniões
de pais porque tem a ver com os filhos
américa faz com que os empreendedores
assim que elas têm menos capacidade
aumento de disponibilidade para assumir
o lugar de chefia e depois vemos que
existem de facto muito menos mulheres em
lugares de chefia e estou a ver que
muitos estudantes universitários por -
vocês parecem todo 25 e um copo que
sejam estudantes universitárias nas
universidades as mulheres estão em
perfeita maioria há mais licenciadas
mais mestrados e mais notadas
sabem quantas chegaram a reitora apenas
três sabem quantas empresas cotadas em
bolsa tem também tiveram mulher cio
apenas uma
e foram estes números da realidade desta
desigualdade de gênero causaram revolta
e que fizeram surgir estes no fim mesmo
o flu mesmo que tenho mais evoluído
é óbvio que quando eu vim pra quem falar
de feminismo numa zona do globo que é
favor sida no mundo as contas nacional
europeu nesta zona e industrializada e
acidental é que nós nem nós nos movemos
vocês podem achar a assistir estatuto
consagrado na lei é vedado falta aplicar
na sociedade e quando vai pra quê pedir
essas coisas todas que no fundo não são
muito mais do que dinheiro é igual a ter
mais oportunidades pedir para que
ninguém fique para trás
convém também lembrarmos do que existem
muitos outros países do globo
convém não esquecer mas que em 23 países
ainda é prometida a mutilação genital
feminina em que jovens crianças e jovens
mulheres são levadas à força e amarradas
para serem cortadas nos genitais
contra a sua vontade não morrerem ficam
com marcas que vão acompanhar para o
resto da vida
convém não esquecer que o apedrejamento
por esse grave crime que é o assunto
sério em de permitido em vários países
como arábia saudita o afeganistão o
emanou síria como lembrarmos da campanha
internacional de sakineh ramina espécie
de culpa que há uns anos em 2010 motivou
uma campanha internacional enorme quando
foi condenada por o planejamento porque
precisamente por suspeitarem que ela
tenha conteúdo adultério mas temos
também outros exemplos como o caso de
marta daleffe uma jovem norueguesa de 24
anos que há quatro anos foi condenada à
prisão por sexo fora do casamento no
dubai ela tenha sido revelada
não é por nós não teremos esta realidade
reforça convém sempre nunca esquecer os
direitos conquistados até aqui porque
foram esses mesmos conquistados não
foram dados de bandeja
não é por nós não temos esta realidade
que não devemos pedir mais igualdades no
fundo estamos a pedir é para as gerações
futuras
melhor solares melhores condições de
vida de fazer com que ninguém tenha medo
de crescer qualquer coisa é fazer com
que as pessoas acreditem mais no seu
potencial independentemente do gênero
com que o cheiro não aceita as políticas
e reformas políticas para isso eu não
tenho soluções milagrosas mas há uma
coisa que eu acho que espera ter um
crente sido comuns pensarmos todos
juntos
muito disso começa na educação o futuro
faz do passado e o passado eu não
apresenta aquilo que nós estamos a dar
mostrar a educar as nossas crianças não
existem sentimentos de menina e
sentimentos do menino não existem kosovo
menino e kosovo menina não existem
brinquedos só do menino e brinquedos só
de menina
o que nós podemos ensinar hoje os nossos
filhos é que os podem ser que os
quiserem
basta ter em talento trabalhar eo que
querem sorte isso nós podemos começar a
mudar já antes nem promete ser
implementadas lais ou outro tipo de
propostas políticas
afinal
começar agora obrigado aveiro
[Música]
[Aplausos]